[Applause]
legislation
[Applause]
[Music]
significant damage to our economy
and do business
and that is
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
super
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
negotiations
[Music]
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
and the emergency preparedness minister
have repeatedly stated that foreign
extremist financing is behind canadian
protests
at public safety committee last week
deputy director of intelligence for
fintrac barry mckillip
stated that there is no evidence to back
up these claims in fact he stated quote
there has not been a spike in suspicious
transactions related to the protest end
quote
why is the prime minister offside with
canada's national security experts
honorable deputy prime minister
[Music]
mr speaker i spoke yesterday with the
head of fintrac and we are in close
touch with that very important
organization
the reality her deputy the reality mr
speaker is
that fintrack
lacked the necessary authorities to
oversee the new world of cryptocurrency
and crowd sourcing and payment platforms
with these measures mr speaker we have
enhanced the authorities of ventrac and
that is allowing us to stop the illegal
funding of these illegal blockades
remember south shuri white rock
mr speaker this morning the prime
minister contradicted two of his
ministers who had stated that the
application of the emergency measures
act would be geographically located the
pm said it would apply to all of canada
all the border crossings in bc alberta
manitoba and ontario have been cleared
the majority of premiers clearly say
this government overreach
is interfering in their jurisdictions
when will the prime minister revoke this
reckless decision and begin rebuilding
the trust of canadians
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know mr speaker once upon a time the
conservative power was a responsible
party
that believed in defending the national
economic interest i know one
conservative minister who served in such
a government
parent beatty who created the
emergencies act
mr beatty said today said this week that
when he brought in the emergencies act
he knew that there would inevitably be
future crises i spoke to mr beatty today
and i told him about the work our
government is doing to defend the
canadian economy
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
business
and exporters
salute that manufacturing
to
canada's reputation as a reliability
for three weeks don't they realize that
the situation would be less dangerous
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker
for democracy
thank you mr speaker
the story of this pandemic has been a
story of solidarity of canadians taking
care of one another
but canadians are now wondering what the
plan is to get out of this pandemic
we know that the plan to get out of this
pandemic has to include
a science-based approach
and it has to include an approach to
invest in our healthcare system so will
the prime minister commit to making sure
health care system is never again in the
fear of collapsing and that we have an
evidence-based plan for us to move past
this
honorable pandemic prime minister
[Applause]
mr speaker
our country is moving past this pandemic
thanks to the hard work
thanks to the common sense of canadians
thanks to the fact that 90 of canadians
are vaccinated thanks to the heroism of
our health care workers and our
essential workers for that reason mr
speaker canada has one of the best
outcomes in the western world when it
comes to mortality rates had we had the
u.s level of mortality mr speaker an
additional 66 000 canadians would have
died we are getting past the pandemic
thanks
[Music]
foreign
to get a strong recovery
[Music]
and we will do that together
his lack of leadership
missing
approaches
and what steps
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
to exceptional legislation without
consulting
the will of those provinces
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
during this crisis
the situation responses
[Applause]
mr speaker
all the resources
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there is no justification
london thank you very much mr speaker
and the lack of this action from this
government has resulted in the reactive
to ending the protests and blockades and
invoking the measures uh the emergencies
measures act is the most reactive step
taken to date mr speaker canadians are
looking for hope and for a plan this
government decided to vote against
having a plan
what proactive steps did the prime
minister actually take prior to putting
in these into these restrictions none
the honorable government house leader
thank you mr speaker and of course we've
been clear of being there every step of
the way to support law enforcement as
this situation continued but i think
it's important to reflect on the steps
the conservative party took during this
process starting with the interim leader
who said that i don't think that we
should ask these people to go home
inferring that they should take this as
a political opportunity the member for
carlton who's a leadership aspirant
saying that i stand with the illegal
activity that's occurring outside
saying that he should keep the momentum
going and of course this continues with
the member for yorkton melville
saskatoon grassland cyprus hills
grassland again and again and again they
encourage the honorable member for elgin
middlesex london and thank you very much
and perhaps the house leader didn't
understand what i'm looking for is an
answer to the plans and what this prime
minister has actually done
step one he stigmatized he traumatized
and he divided canadians just as this
house leader is doing today step two he
hid in the cottage he did not react when
things were going on there we did not
hear from the prime minister step three
he whipped his caucus where every single
member with exception one voted against
a plan mr speaker this leadership has
failed period failed what actions did
the prime minister actually take prior
to putting in these restrictions
the honorable government house leader
every one of us walks through what is
going on outside every day we see uh the
residents of
ottawa be terrorized by this illegal
occupation that's occurring and i want
to ask the members opposite will they
stand today clearly every single one of
them and say it's time to go home will
they stand every single one of them to
stop tweeting stop encouraging stop
saying things like keep the momentum
going and instead
ask for those folks who are outside to
go home to make sure that this illegal
activity is not something that a party
that's supposed to be standing for law
and order uh stands with
[Music]
is
and vaccination centers
[Applause]
thank you very much
is
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
to guarantee the sovereignty security
and territorial integrity of canada
but none of this is under threat
according to the law you have to be in a
national emergency that's not the case
here
what does the law allow
temporary extraordinary measures that
may not be justifiable
mr speaker canada's territorial
integrity issues
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
should not be deprived
[Music]
well earlier this week i asked the
finance minister what she was doing to
control the skyrocketing cost of living
all she did was shift blame and she
avoided the question yesterday we
received the news that we were all
dreading stats canada says the consumer
price index rose 5.1 percent in january
the worst it's been in over 30 years mr
speaker
paychecks no longer go as far as they
used to and canadians are getting left
far behind so i will ask again what
specifically is the minister doing to
get inflation under control
[Applause]
mr speaker
unlike the conservatives canadians
understand that inflation is a global
phenomenon
and here are some numbers to back that
up
the latest inflation number in canada
was 5.1
in the u.s it was 7.5
percent
in the uk it is 5.5
our inflation is lower than the g7
average which is 5.5 the g20 average
which is 6.1 is oecd average of 6.5
canadians understand mr speaker it's
time for the conservatives to understand
as well member for abbotsford
well for months now this liberal
minister has been claiming that
inflation was transitory nothing to see
here folks and this week's stats canada
proved the minister wrong inflation is
up again at 5.1 percent the highest it's
been over 30 years prices for fish up 8
for beef up 12
bacon 19
how does this minister expect canadians
to put food on the table when is this
government going to realize that it has
lost complete control over inflation
the honorable deputy prime minister
mr speaker i think it was actually the
chairman of the federal reserve who used
the term transitory to characterize
inflation
but let me just point out yet again that
the conservatives continue to push a
false narrative frankly about everything
that is happening in canada and very
much including the economy the fact is
the canadian recovery is strong our gdp
grew by 5.4
in the third quarter that beat the us
japan the uk and australia and i also
want to point out
that s p and moody's both reaffirmed our
aaa credit rating this fall
is
[Applause]
implemented
[Music]
mr speaker canada is one of the biggest
funders of oil and gas in the g20 a new
study showed that last year alone the
government through export development
canada handed out 4.4 billion dollars
earning canada the worst possible
climate score that's despite repeated
liberal promises to phase out fossil
fuels subsidies we are in a climate
emergency and edc is fueling the crisis
so why
not know anybody make a dream edc clean
up its act stop
[Applause]
i'm sorry that was uh that was a
technical error where somebody had their
microphone on i'm going to ask the
honourable member for victoria to start
from the top so that we can hear her
full question the honorable member for
victoria
mr speaker canada is one of the biggest
funders of oil and gas in the g20 a new
study showed that last year alone the
government through export development
canada handed out 4.4 billion dollars
earning canada the worst possible
climate score that's despite repeated
liberal promises to phase out fossil
fuel subsidies we are in a climate
emergency and edc is fueling the crisis
so why won't the government make edc
clean up its act stop giving billions to
big oil and gas and start standing up
for canadians
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and i thank my
honorable colleague for her question in
fact g20 countries i've committed to
eliminate fossil fuel subsidies by 2025
we in canada have committed to doing
that by 2023 two years earlier than our
g20 colleagues mr speaker and on top of
that edc has reduced its fossil fuel
subsidies by more than three billion
dollars per year since 2018. thank you
mr speaker the honourable member for
timmins james bay
earlier this week i made an accusation
against the environment minister that
his government had held 370 backroom
meetings with big oil in just two years
mr speaker i withdraw those comments
because it turns out they'd actually
rolled out the red carpet for
1224 meetings with big oil that my
friends is the definition of carbon
captured so it's no wonder that under
this prime minister canada has fallen to
the bottom of the g7 in terms of climate
action so to the environment minister
when's he going to stop acting as the
head butler for the oil lobby and start
standing up for canadians
the honorable minister of the
environment thank you mr speaker and i
thank my honourable colleague for his
question
one of the highest carbon price in the
world here in canada regulations on
methane pollution 40 reduction by 2025 a
cap on oil and gas emissions these are
all things our government has done to
fight climate change and ensuring we
create good jobs and a prosperous future
for all canadians thank you mr speaker
honourable member for northwest
territories
[Music]
mr speaker this tuesday 54 potential
unmarked graves were found at casey
cousy first nation three weeks ago
williams lake first nation announced
that the survey had identified 93
potential unmarked graves on the site of
the former st joseph mission residential
school nearly a year ago canada was
rocked by the discovery of 200 probable
unmarked graves on the grounds of the
former cameron which is indian
residential school
despite all this evidence some still
deny the actual legacy of residential
schools and claim the number of unmarked
graves is exaggerated mr speaker i find
this very troubling and unacceptable
could the minister of crown indigenous
relations comment on what our government
is doing to support the survivors of
these residential schools
and i just want to say that there is
accommodation that takes place in the
chamber sometimes technically it doesn't
always work i believe we had everything
tested that worked out fairly well i
believe the translation took place
[Music]
a little bit of compassion so that we
can all work together in the house
the honorable minister
last summer in light of the devastating
findings in kamloops and calluses our
government announced an additional 329
million dollars to support indigenous
communities in their search for loved
ones rob at such a young age in their
efforts to memorialize their loss and
their quest for closure
residential schools were a reality in
this country for well over 150 years and
the effects are still felt painfully
today to the survivors who are speaking
out including my friend and member who
spoke as well as those who continue
to suffer in silence
we believe you canada believes you
the honorable member for fort mcmurray
cold lake
[Applause]
mr speaker the prime minister is out of
step with canadians canadians want and
deserve open dialogue after two years of
uncertainty
this should be about science not
political science yet this prime
minister would rather divide and
stigmatize instead of giving people the
certainty and hope they need
when will the prime minister stop
doubling down on divisive rhetoric and
commit publicly to a specific plan and
timeline to end federal mandates and
restrictions
the honourable parliamentary secretary
thank you mr speaker since day one of
this pandemic our government's focus has
been the health and safety of our con of
our neighbors by following the latest
science the most recent data indicates
that the omicron wave is past its peak
in canada which allows us to move
towards a more long-term approach to
managing covid19 we intend to follow the
science and we're working closely with
experts like dr tam and other public
health officials to ensure that we
continue to get through this pandemic
together
as best we possibly can and that has
been through vaccinations thank you mr
speaker the honourable member for a wren
for nipissing pembroke mr speaker the
prime minister's petulance led to the
firing of ottawa's first black police
chief during black history month it's
yet another example of the divisiveness
fostered by this government
the prime minister's own finance
minister stood on the maidan during
ukraine's revolution
canadians want foreign interference from
the prime minister's jet setting
resetters to stop
when will the prime minister
listen to the majority of freedom-loving
canadians and end the mandates
the honorable government house leader
mr speaker i've had and i'm sure all
members have had the opportunity to talk
to people who come from countries that
aren't free that know what it means to
have their freedoms restricted in ways
that are not able to live or to share
their thoughts or to protest in peaceful
ways but i'm sure and i would hope that
the member opposite would agree that
what we're seeing outside
the terrorizing of residents the
harassing of homeless shelters the
inability for ottawa citizens to
continue their life has gone way too
far please stop supporting these illegal
activities and join with us so that our
lives can begin to return to normal
the honorable member
mr speaker the science has changed
canada's top officials including dr tam
have recommended review of covet
policies we're seeing countries around
the world with lower vaccination rates
and canada dropping their restrictions
we're seeing provinces our own country
dropping restrictions is the government
going to stick toward and follow the
science when will
the mandates for canadian travelers who
are fully vaccinated
and when will the mandates be totally
dropped for the testing for canadian
travelers to return
the honourable parliamentary secretary
peter this transition including this
week's announcement is possible because
of a number number of factors which
includes our high vaccination rates and
the increasing availability of rapid
tests and treatments as we've said all
along canada's border measures will
remain flexible and adaptable guided by
science and prudence i have a quote from
my uh my colleague opposite and that is
it starts here everyone entering canada
by land as well as by air irrespective
of their vaccination status will be
required to take a rapid test or
possibly a pcr test where's that from
that's from page 19 of the conservatives
election platform remember this magazine
that one thanks mr speaker
the honorable member for new brunswick
southwest
well mr speaker
life moves on and the government needs
to move on with it in december the
liberals again impose rigid covet 19
testings on canadians living in border
communities who travel to the united
states and return home often within a
day or within a few hours
the lib the liberals announced
they would replace
72-hour pcr testing with a 24-hour rapid
test
this doesn't help our border communities
24-hour testing will continue to
separate families and people in canada's
border towns
when will the liberals allow canadians
to drive to the united states and come
home in a single day without testing
thank you mr speaker the honorable
parliamentary secretary to the minister
of health thank you mr speaker i'd
remind the member again that uh you
campaigned on testing as well just like
we did uh well we're in a better
position today than we were previously
this pandemic's not over yet we all want
this pandemic to be over but it's not
over yet the government of canada will
continue to assess the evolving
situation here at home and globally and
while the members opposite continue to
shout me down it doesn't change the the
reality that this pandemic is not yet
over thank you members
foreign
[Applause]
um
uh
okay
manifestations
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
afghan refugees were ignored liberal
ministers were briefed months before
kabul fell these warnings were ignored
my letters to the prime minister and the
ministers continue to be ignored afghan
refugees write to this government every
day pleading for help they continue to
be ignored the afghan crisis is another
pattern of inaction and failures in
leadership by this liberal government
why was an action why was an election
plan and abandoning those that served
canada more important than the pleas of
afghan refugees
the honorable minister of immigration
mr speaker when that member first asked
me a question about the success of our
resettlements and uh efforts in
afghanistan there was 3 800 afghan
refugees in canada today there are more
than 7 700 in the past few weeks mr
speaker we have seen more than 460
arrive on 20 commercial flights there
are more flights arriving every week we
have made one of the most substantial
commitments of any country in the world
not just on a per capita basis but in
terms of the raw number of human beings
that we are going to welcome to give a
second lease on life canadians should be
proud of the effort that we're making
and we will not waver until we are
successful in resettling all 40 000
afghan refugees who will call canada
home
[Applause]
and expect
[Applause]
during the evacuation there was an
emergency situation and we responded as
quickly as it's humanly possible one of
the reasons mr speaker that i think the
honourable member will appreciate is
that we no longer had a military
presence with the logistics capability
of moving thousands and thousands of
people on our own because we hadn't had
a military presence there since 2014. mr
speaker we worked with international
partners to rescue thousands of people
in the moments of the evacuation i want
to say thank you to my predecessor now
the minister of public safety for his
efforts to resell thousands of afghan
refugees and i'm going to finish the job
the honourable member
owen sound
mr speaker here's some of the damning
testimony this week from retired
generals about the liberal government's
failure during the fall of kabul and the
government's continued lack of
leadership quote we were the first
embassy to depart that was very
embarrassing
quote when this crisis was unfolding
right in front of our eyes we had then
as we do now urge the government to
create an interdepartmental task force
with one leader mr speaker i'll ask the
same question i asked last week will the
prime minister assign one lead minister
to solve this ongoing humanitarian aid
crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i am the minister who's been appointed
by the prime minister to lead this
effort we will collaborate with other
ministers including the minister of
global affairs to help ensure that we
are successful in partnering with the
global community to see this mission
succeed i heard the members opposite
tackling about the timing of the
election when it came to the afghan
refugee resettlement effort and i would
point out how important that election
was because we campaigned on a
commitment to increase our level of
ambition from twenty thousand to forty
thousand their commitment on the other
side while they heckle me was to welcome
precisely zero afghan refugees more than
that mr speaker they campaigned to end
the government assisted refugees program
altogether which has been responsible
for saving thousands of lives
foreign
[Applause]
mr speaker the liberals made in canada
housing crisis has gotten out of control
it's the same situation across the
country including my community at york
simcoe working canadians have been
priced out of the housing market with no
hope in sight now home builders are
stopping the construction of new homes
liberal inflation has caused prices for
material to skyrocket there are too many
ways for builders there's no way for
builders to know the fair market value
of the home that won't be ready for at
least two years why is this liberal
government making it even harder for
canadians to own a home great question
[Applause]
the conservatives are not really serious
about housing affordability because
every single time we've brought a
measure here to enable canadians to be
able to afford a home they voted against
it the first time home buyer incented
all the measures that we've brought they
even voted against imposing a vacancy
tax on foreign owned non-resident
properties so they're not serious
they're full of rhetoric and canadians
see through them we will take additional
measures to improve the first time home
buy incentive and and turn more canadian
renters into home owners let's see if
they vote against that
the honorable member for yellow head
mr speaker 400 billion newly created
cash has driven up consumer prices and
constituents in my riding especially
seniors can't afford their basic
necessities in addition to rising
consumer prices electricity and heating
bills are increasing due to the carbon
tax which is to increase again on april
1st
mr speaker when will this liberal
government finally quit making false
promises and create a real economic plan
for all canadians especially those who
struggling to meet their basic needs
[Applause]
mr speaker
the conservative mp began his question
talking about government spending which
he seems to deem excessive so i'd like
to remind him that he
together with every single conservative
there
actually ran on an election platform
proposing higher spending in 21 22 than
the liberals did they proposed 168
billion deficit we proposed 150 billion
deficit so could the party of flip-flops
tell canadians what they stand for today
the honourable member for brantford
brandt mr speaker with more than 1.3
million unemployed canadians two hundred
thousand jobs were lost in january alone
at the same time our businesses are
struggling to fill almost one million
jobs
canada's economic recovery is in
jeopardy canada has the fifth worst job
recovery in the g7
hard-working people at brantford-brant
are asking when will the prime minister
stop putting his ideological agenda
above prudent economic decisions
you know mr speaker it is a bit rich to
hear the conservatives talk about their
support for canadian workers and
canadian jobs and let me just point out
one moment of abject conservative
failure and that was before christmas
when we knew we knew omicron was coming
we knew canadian workers and businesses
needed support but you know what the
conservatives voted against that measure
and when it comes to jobs canada has
recovered 101 of the jobs lost to covet
u.s just 87 mr speaker
for london west mr speaker some working
low-income seniors in this country have
had a challenging time making ends meet
during this pandemic which is why they
turn to what most canadians did the crb
and other pandemic benefits while we're
going to be supporting people who
suffered drops in their gis and
allowance through compensation payments
the minister of seniors mandate letter
also called us to look to look forward
it called us to assure seniors that we'd
have their backs even more can the
minister tell this house how she's done
that
honorable minister for seniors thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i'd like to thank
the member for london west for her
question and for her advocacy for
seniors in her riding she's right we
committed to ensuring seniors
eligibility for the gis and alliance
will not be impacted by receiving
pandemic benefits and this helps
yesterday mr speaker unanimously passed
bill c-12 and i want to take an
opportunity to thank every member in
this house and making that happen i look
forward to seeing it make its way
through the other place mr speaker it's
clear for seniors with the greatest
needs that we will always have their
backs
the honorable member for edmonton
strathcona
mr speaker 1.5 million ukrainians have
been displaced from their homes since
russia invaded in 2014. now as russia
amasses troops and armaments and
threatens further invasion the ukrainian
people need canada more than ever there
is a looming humanitarian disaster in
ukraine and thousands of ukrainians are
seeking refuge in canada we saw this
government fail to protect afghans we
can't let this happen again will the
minister uphold canada's responsibility
to ukrainians will the minister ensure
humanitarian aid and better support for
those ukrainians who are fleeing
violence
minister or the armed parliamentary
secretary thank you uh mr speaker uh
there is no situation that is we are
more seized with right now than ukraine
and our solidarity for the ukrainian
government and the people of ukraine we
have also been very clear
that we are standing with canadian
citizens who are in ukraine and any
possible humanitarian crisis that could
extend following a possible incursion
right now however our mission is to
de-escalate russia's uh
total disrespect for the territorial
integrity of ukraine we will stand with
the people of ukraine whether it's
militarily whether it is through
humanitarian assistance and by helping
uh every ukrainian who is in trouble
the honorable member for spadina for
york
thank you mr speaker i recently met with
representatives from the undergraduates
of canadian research intensive
universities they represent over a
quarter million students from u15
universities that annually conduct eight
and a half billion dollars of research
and contribute more than 36 billion
dollars to our economy like most
students i meet with in spadina fort
york there's a shared concern crippling
student debt the average lifetime
interest on a candid student loan is
three thousand dollars due to the
pandemic the government waived the
interest for two years mr speaker more
must be done can the parliamentary
secretary to the minister of employment
workforce development and disability
inclusion inform this house when will
the government permanently eliminate
interest on canada student loans
the honorable
parliamentary secretary
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
honorable colleague for his question
young canadians and students must be at
the center of our recovery and we're
proud that our response during the
pandemic was one of the largest youth
support packages in the world during the
pandemic our government waived the
interest on canada student loans and
canada apprentice loans for two years
because we knew young people were
amongst the hardest hit by job losses
that's why we are committed to
permanently eliminating the federal
interest on csl and canada apprentice
loans supporting over one million
students we're also committed to
increasing the repayment assistance
threshold to fifty thousand dollars for
canada student loan borrowers we will
continue to be there mr speaker to help
canadians transition into the workforce
thank you